If you want to visit a place that would be featured in a magazine like National Geographic,...
...you should not miss this place in Turkey.
You would be overwhelmed by the breathtaking scenery of Pamukkale,...
...which means "cotton castle" in Turkish.
This is a tranquil place where you could meditate in silence.
When you arrive at this hot spot,...
...you will observe a 100-meter-high rock platform covered in pools and terraces...
...that bring to mind a frozen waterfall.
Water from the hot springs gathers in pools that fill up and overflow into smaller pools,...
...splashing happily as it cascades down among bushes of oleander.
In colder weather, the flowing water creates mists above the pools, which adds a special magic.
Throughout the year, you can bathe in around 33 degrees Celsius...
...in open-air swimming pools at hotels and motels, as well as on the terraces.
This place would give you unforgettable moments.